I’m Emad Khazaree, I am a fellow at Berkman
Klein Center for Internet and Society, and
I’m also an Assistant Professor of Information
at Kent State’s School of Information in
Ohio.
Broadly, speaking, I’m interested in how
human collectives use information technology
to achieve their collective goals.
I look at two levels.
At one level, I look at very large collectives,
how they use information technology for social
transformations, for example, how activists
use information technology to challenge authorities.
On another level, I’m looking at very tightly
connected communities, I call them communities
of practice, how they use information technologies
to produce knowledge.
At Berkman Klein Center, I am looking to understand
how we can theorize the dynamic of evolution
of the tools and methods that activists use
to challenge authorities.
On a personal side, I’m Iranian and I have
seen a lot of transformations in recent years
happening in Iranian society.
We’ve seen a very young population, educated
population, use information technology to
progress the state of society.
We are living in an era that the pace of technology,
changes and advancements, is so high, that
some people have become anxious about what
the impact of technology is in our society.
It’s very important to see whether it helps
us to improve our society or not.
I think that’s how it is important for the
average person, to see, in many contexts,
such as oppressive environments, whether the
use of information technology can be a force
shifting the balance towards a more just and
progressive society, or it might give more
tools for oppressive governments to repress
and restrict humans’ freedom.